Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today is our first workshop
on our live course, the complete guide to
Teleport.
Oh, it's gonna be fun. I hope.
Good to see you in the chat. Hey,
Nuno. Hey, Kevin.
It's been a while. I have been away
for
six weeks, maybe longer on paternity leave. I
surprised I even remember how to turn this
thing on, but here I am. I hope
my audio is okay. Feel free to let
me know in a chat
and we'll
kind of run through what we're going to
do today.
So you may have noticed in the Complete
Guide to Teleport course, we've had a couple
of tutorials published in the last week. We
have taken a look at installing and running
Teleport.
We looked at installing through package managers on
Red Hat and Debian or Debian derivatives as
well.
We took a look at installing it through
DNF or Yum on Red Hat systems.
And we take a look at
installing it through using curl, right, for any
other Linux distribution where using a package manager
is not really an option. So it's pretty
simple. The videos are there. Please feel free
to go and check them out.
The second tutorial, we take a look at,
well, what if we want to run Teleport
using containers and with Docker? And what if
we want to do this locally?
There are a few gotchas that the tutorial
covers,
making sure that you persist your state, you
handle configuration appropriately,
and we even take a look at using
Docker Compose for a lab like environment with
multiple nodes within your Teleport cluster.
So we're following on from that today. Our
first workshop is going to be anywhere between,
I think, sixty to ninety minutes. It's hard
to tell these things.
I don't run through the workshops in advance
as with all things on my channel.
I come up with a concept and then
we do it live. So I've come up
with, let me share.
Hey, Carlos, thank you for joining us today.
So let's pop over here.
You can go to the Rawkode Academy GitHub
page that is github.com/rockwoodacademy.
From there, you will see a courses repository
and we have a directory for the Teleport
Complete Guide.
Instead of here, we have part five, which
is this workshop
where we are gonna take a look at
server access and all the cool things that
Teleport brings to the table.
I've set myself 15 tasks.
These are tasks that I was wrapping
my brain around, right? If we want people
to
play with Teleport, get excited by Teleport, love
Teleport enough to deploy it to all of
their infrastructures, which I think everyone should do,
then we have to walk them through a
series of steps to show them the value
add to Teleport brings.
And each of these questions hopefully allow you
to learn the primitives and the basics of
working with Teleport and lead you down that
path of the holy shit, this is really
cool.
I haven't run through it, like I said
myself, we're gonna do it all together.
Everything on my channel is about live. I
like it this way. We're going to leverage
the documentation as much as possible. The Teleport
docs are great
and we're going to use that whenever we
get stuck and hopefully have a little bit
of fun.
Feel free to chat away in the chat,
ask questions, please. Any questions you have along
the way, drop them in. I'll do my
best to answer them.
And we're really just going to get started
with this thing.
What have I done upfront?
Well, I created in this directory,
we have a
small
Pulumi
project
that just runs a couple of Linodes,
Y Linode.
It's pretty cheap. I just need small VMs.
So we're going with that today.
I've already spun them up, we don't need
to wait for that to run. You will
see that I have a Teleport server,
three working nodes. There's nothing installed on these.
We're going to do all of this together.
So hopefully if you want to try this
out, you can use the Pulumi, but of
course, if you just want to spin up
some AWS instances, you want to use containers
using the lab environment from the previous tutorial,
feel free to do that. It's entirely up
to you. If you have Bit Metal, hell,
go have some fun.
Okay. So exercise one is that we want
to create the Teleport server.
We need a single node in our cluster
that is going to act as the central
point for authentication and proxying,
and we need to be able to get
that up and running.
Exercise one just says that we want to
use one of our servers to install and
create a Teleport server
with a static authentication
token
for agents
to join the cluster at our next exercise.
Cool.
Well, let's get the documentation up, which I
should have done in advance.
You can go to goteleport.com,
click on doc docs,
and we can just use the, get started
guide, click on Linux. And this has pretty
much everything that we need. I'm going to
use the curl approach, which is here.
We've got our first question already from Carlos.
So
Carlos says, is this a single point of
failure and how do you handle that?
Excuse me.
You know, I'm pretty confident that it's all
behind enterprise.
If you need a highly available Teleport control
plane, I believe enterprise is the option.
I am not aware of any ability to
do that through the open source product. However,
I could be wrong. And so I will
post a follow-up
and we'll do a tutorial on that, but
I'm pretty sure it is behind enterprise.
What I would recommend is if you are
worried about high availability,
there is Teleport Cloud. You can check out
that and maybe you can just I'm not
entirely familiar with what the costs are, but
maybe you could just use their cloud SaaS
offering
and then you would get enterprise
level, highly available control plan without any risk.
User two chatty.
Kevin is then there saying you can run
it in HE with the open source version,
but you have to do it by hand.
There you go. I mean, I guess if
you can so there's multiple ways to configure
the control plane. I guess if you're doing
it through X509 certificate authentication,
you know, if you can configure the same
search and you have state that can be
synced across the machines, then I guess that
would work that way.
We'll dive into that maybe later in the
course, I'll see if I can squeeze that
in.
Okay. Let's get
on the source machine.
So here is my IP address
for my Teleport server.
I've got a BSSH.
I've forgotten how to computer.
My password
is not sole secret.
But this does get me onto the machine.
I do not have T control,
TSH
or Teleport.
So there's nothing available on this machine.
Let us download
the
Extract the tarball.
And it just wants us to do sudo
install inside of this directory.
I'm root, so I don't need to worry
about that.
And it will tell us that
we have installed Teleport and
we now have TCTL,
TSH
and a Teleport command.
So that is our several, at least we've
got the binaries available on our server machine.
So
one of the things we covered in our
previous tutorial was that Teleport ships with a
Teleport configure command that is going to give
us a base config to allow us to
get started pretty quickly.
We can jump into ETC.
We can make a Teleport
and we can run teleport configure,
teleport.
Yaml.
And if we want to start making changes
to this, we have the configuration here.
One of the things you'll notice I did
in the tutorials was throw away the node
name, we allow the Teleport runtime to infer
this from the host name of the machine,
but one of the tasks on
our workshop exercise one is that we need
static authentication token for the agents.
So what does that mean? Well, let's see.
When we
Sorry, trying to keep up with the chat
here.
These are still talking about highly available control
plans. Carlos is asking about Kubernetes deployments.
There is a Kubernetes workshop
either next week or the following week where
we take
a look at the different deployment scenarios on
Kubernetes.
So join us for that for sure.
Nuno saying, you thought I was going to
use TCSH?
And
then more chat about AG. All right, cool.
So when we talk about authentication,
the way that the Teleport model works is
that we have the server
and then we deploy Teleport
server to the other machines, but we only
run them in agent mode,
which just means that they have like the
authentication service disabled, the proxy service disabled.
They're really just connecting best to the server
to be able to join the cluster.
The way that these work is that you
can either create tokens
to do,
you can generate femoral tokens that you pass
to the agents that register and then those
tokens can expire, but the nodes not remembers
the cluster, or you can define a static
token that works for as
long as the server is configured with that
token, at least. There's lots of ways to
secure it down and we'll be looking at
production best practices and security of your Teleport
control plane
and tutorials, follow into the course, but we're
not going to talk about that today, but
there's cool things like CA pending to make
sure that we get the right search back
and such. But today we're just going with
a static join token, which means we just
need to configure our off service with an
arbitrary string. And if any of the
agents have that string, they will be allowed
to join as an agent of the cluster.
Carlos in the chat is asking which language
is Teleport written in?
Almost exclusively in Go with the front end
and TypeScript and React,
I believe.
Okay.
So we already have off service and enabled
here.
So we need to add tokens
followed by this
string.
So we want to say that we want
to enable token authentication,
and we won't use their string.
We'll see Rawkode
Academy.
So we can save that. And now
if we run a systemd teleport
start,
I'm pretty sure there's a service available.
Start teleport.
No.
I thought there was. Maybe not with the
curl installation.
Yeah. Computer said no. So what we're going
to do is a Teleport
start.
I'm pretty sure I've got my config in
the right location.
I think so. If not, I can make
it explicit. Let's just make it explicit. Let's
remove any room for error.
I don't trust myself.
So we're gonna start out like that. We
can just pass the dash C, which tells
us to load an explicit config and relatively
confident this is the correct path and it
was configured this way anyway, but it's fine.
Cool.
Now we can check that this works
by browsing to the public IPv4 address of
our Teleport server,
and we should be presented with the login
screen.
Nope. HTTPS
is what I wanted.
Now I haven't configured
any x five zero nine certificates.
So as Teleport does it itself,
It does have built in
ACMELetsEncrypt
support. So if I were to go and
create a DNS record for
this IP address, we could go into the
config and enable that. When we look at
best practices,
we will be covering certificates
in much more detail there. So that'll be
in a week or two.
We don't have a user yet, so we're
going to quickly create one for that.
And we can do that. I may as
well have to split this. We get SSH
should be the same, nope.
IP address.
My
super secret password,
Really should have enabled key authentication.
Alright. And now we can create a user.
So to create a user, we're going to
do t control,
users add Rawkode.
Don't worry about rules or anything like that
now, we're going to cover that shortly.
This gets me a link here,
which I just have to replace with my
IP address.
And I can actually change the configuration with
a bit more information. In fact, the node
name probably set to this would have tabbed
that up.
We're going to generate a password.
Teleport
workshop.
And I'll just need to copy that again.
I don't know why it doesn't put it
in both. We have one password bug.
And my favorite feature in one password is
scanning
the QR code.
There we go.
Sweet.
Okay, let's jump back to this. So we
have created a Teleport server
with a static authentication token for agents.
The part two is we want to wash
our system and repeat. We want to actually
add these other nodes to our system.
Let's grab this IP address. I'm going to
really regret copying and pasting this password now.
Let's just keep the splits coming. So I
need my next IP address.
And I need my password.
And one more.
Last time for the password, I hope.
And then we're going to
Not cheat,
but we're going to use iTerms
session
copy thingy.
Where is it?
Broadcast
current tab.
Yes.
Perfect. Okay. And now we can do the
installation all at the same time.
We'll jump back over to our
documentation.
I'm pretty sure we still have Linux here.
Copy this.
Now these are all different operating systems. I
could use package managers,
but let's just go with the binary because
I can copy and paste everything.
So the first machine I think is that
we'll test in a second.
Not
all of them have it, you name Dashie.
We have Debian,
Arch.
This one should be Red Hat. Let's see,
DNF. Yeah, cool.
Okay, so extract,
Teleport,
CD Teleport.
Oh, the first one's not finished yet.
It's
gonna work.
They're a little bit of a sync, but
we're getting there.
Cool.
TCPL.
Yeah, our first debug machine is lagging a
little bit, but we get over it. We
now have Teleport installed all of these now.
So we can do Teleport.
We can do Mictur
Teleport,
Teleport configure
to Teleport.
YAML.
And this is where I'm really going to
need them all to be in sync.
Oh, look at that.
How does that seg fault?
What?
They're all
X8664.
I think that Damien machine is going to
disappear.
I'm curious about this four nineteen kernel.
So we're just gonna kill
Debian one.
Can I close this without closing them all?
Yeah, cool. All right, we're going with a
two node cluster plus the control plane.
Okay,
so we are going to remove node names,
off service,
no.
Proxy service,
And actually,
if we come to
set up,
and then guides.
Where's
the
I'm going to have to just remember.
No, it must be an against our ticket.
So what we're doing next is now that
we have a conflict where the service is
disabled that we need is we need to
then tell Teleport where the off server is.
It's just something like,
what's the IP address?
This
and a
token.
But that tutorial was recorded a couple of
weeks ago and I don't remember exactly the
sentence. So let's find it.
We come here.
Pretty sure it's in against the Arctic Gate.
I didn't know if that's the one.
All right. So we've got a static token.
Where's the YAML version?
Off server, okay. So we got that and
token. Okay, I think I got this right.
So we've done the server,
Okay, there we go. Teleport off servers.
Okay. Close. It's not off server, it's multiples.
And it's a list.
And the token
off token.
Okay. That was pretty close.
We can save
this
and run Teleport start
pointing it to our configuration.
And
okay.
So what happened here
is
that the X519 certificate that we configured
on the other site is only for our
local host. So we need to make one
more change.
If we come into our Teleport
on,
oh, it's got a
proxy
service, the listen address,
as we can add a web
listen
ADR
and add our
IP address.
And I'm going to confirm that that is
correct
because I'm sure I'll get that wrong too.
Web lesson ADR, we've got an example.
No,
I can't remember if it includes the port.
Web
listen.
Reference,
config fail.
This is my favorite page in the docs.
There we go.
So
if you're ever trying to work at what
you can and cannot configure,
what I normally do is
go to set up reference config file, and
this is everything the config file accepts with
some documentation on it.
You, roughly, I was looking for the web
lesson ADDR,
couldn't remember what the thing was here.
And also
as a nice reminder, actually there's a public
address for putting the IP address or a
host name. So we're actually going to use
that and not change the web listing address.
So
public ADDR,
We want our IP address, don't need to
port, I do.
So
if we save that configuration,
we'll restart this process.
May have to nuke the certs, we're going
to find out. Where's my terminal gone?
This one's all right.
So this is just crashed on me.
I did not build time into this workshop
for things to crash on me.
Have our Teleport.
Yeah, so there's our PAMs.
I'm gonna nuke.
Then
I'll need to regain my user.
We're about to start breaking Teleport and see
what happens. I'm gonna remove the web proxy
key inserts to see if it will regenerate
them for me. And I'm going to run
a Teleport star.
I'm sure anyone from Teleport watching this is
like, what the hell are you doing?
No TLS, keys provided, using self safe. Perfect.
They're generating new keys.
Carlos,
why am I using Vim? Humans can't use
Vim. Sorry, man. Pico,
that's a bit old school.
Okay.
We've got Teleport running once more. So let's
try
starting our agents again.
What?
Okay. Why is that not working? Just updated
that.
Let's take a look at the cert.
So we're gonna do v
https.
Oh no, v is telling me here, bad
cert.
Oh, what have I done?
Four thirty, eighty.
It should show me this cert, please.
Kevin, if you want to write the playbook,
in fact, I think there is an Ansible
integration in the documentation that I came across
at some point, but probably already a thing.
So here's my server certificate.
Which just says localhost.
I haven't had this problem before.
I'm gonna delete those PAMs again. What have
I forgotten?
If it's that node name, I'm going be
really annoyed with myself.
Let's use our reference.
Let's think.
Serps.
Okay.
Let's see what we have.
We have a listener address and we have
a public address.
Oh, wait, that's on the off surface, that's
not on the
The proxy. I might have just been a
complete idiot.
No. I did it on the proxy service.
WebListen,
we don't need because we're doing everything. Public
address.
Hey, that looks fine.
That looks fine.
Public address.
Well, it can take a public IP address
or a DNS name.
I'm gonna take the hat and re gen
my user and hope that maybe this is
just
something weird and state directory.
And I am gonna run a Teleport start
with my config.
And when I confirm my config flag before
I mess that up to
dash c.
And the default path is etcteleport.
Yaml. I got that longer anyway. Teleport,
teleport.
Generating the search.
My IP address there is.
Okay. So my IP address is definitely here.
Let's try this.
It's a good thing I like these kinds
of things. Alright. Carol,
kv,
hps,
p address.
Done here, 3080.
So it just says local host.
But we did see the cert here.
Ah,
nice tip there, no no.
Perhaps the
servers are cached on the agents.
No.
Maybe I should read the error message.
Okay. I don't wanna see a pen and
we'll do that in another episode.
Not sure to establish connection to the cluster.
If 509 certificate is valid for blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
So this could, I think I am just
being really silly here actually.
Then we changed the public address on the
proxy service, but the agents connect over the
off service,
Not on port 38125.
Let's just keep deleting stuff.
Just in case.
Now this has gone through the 3080 service.
You know what? I'm going to just tell
it that I don't care.
I'm pretty sure there is a teleport
start
parameter
to ignore
key checks
and secure.
Will that get me past it?
No.
Okay. That actually did get us past it.
This is a different error mode saying that
this node
cannot join the cluster because the token doesn't
allow the node role.
Yep.
That's because of this string here, which tells
us
which
capabilities
we have.
And I think
if I do node
Connection.
Yeah. I'm not gonna tell if we're started.
Cool.
So let's talk about what went wrong there
and why.
So when we define a static token as
this in the documentation,
so
that would be a bit
better to reference it instead of here.
It has different rules.
Node,
that's too generic a term.
It doesn't matter. So
when you're defining a static token and your
Teleport
configuration on the server side, which is this
one here,
You put the capabilities
on the left hand side and then the
static token on the right hand side. So
you can have multiple static tokens that give
different capabilities. One could be to just join
another cluster,
one could be trusted cluster, there's proxy, there's
access for applications,
etcetera, right? So all these nodes will have
different capabilities within the Teleport system.
What I forgot to do was add node.
So this couldn't join to the cluster and
join as a node because we never get
the trusted token that capability.
So when we restarted it and did it,
we now have a Teleport cluster. Unfortunately, I
do now need to recreate my user.
That's the role, equals admin login, equals root.
Users.
Because we set the public address, we no
longer have to change anything here.
And
accept
provided I just kind of edit the one
I set up and remove the two FA.
We can just reuse that.
So,
all right, I'm doing that bit off screen.
That's just where one password popped up. So
I'm just going to say reuse the password.
Copy the password.
While I'm here, I'll tell it to scan.
Let's copy the code when I did that
too. Copy password.
And,
there we go.
Okay.
That was fun.
So now you'll see that we have our
total cluster
with our three nodes available.
Our host names are about all over the
shop
because I thought those were configured by Pulumi
for me. Clearly I've messed that up, but
that's okay.
We have the addresses and we have the
labels.
So if we come back to our workshop,
exercise two after thirty seven minutes is complete.
So now we are going to add some
static labels to the Teleport nodes. Labels allow
us to query
our infrastructure using the labels. So if we're
just looking for certain environments and in fact,
the exercise to hear is like, hey, we're
actually going to use the same Teleport cluster
for our staging or QA pre prod testing
environments.
So we need labels to be able to
target and isolate the machines for the things
that we wish to do.
So again, we're just going to use the
documentation whenever possible,
add labels,
it's really easy, especially static labels. We're just
gonna add them to the
Teleport. Yaml configuration file.
The syntax for this,
it's here.
You can add labels and we can use
any key values
that we wish.
Nice and simple.
So let's jump over here. The exercise wants
us to add an environment stage and labels
to the nodes.
Carlos is asking what's the trick to type
on two servers at the same time. So
this is using iTerm2.
That just means that I can come to
Shell
Broadcast Input and I'm using the Broadcast Input
to All Panes in the current tab.
Let's pop open our Teleport configuration.
We'll use the SSH service. We've already got
our example label in here.
We're going to take that off,
environment
staging.
And if we run our Teleport start command
and jump back over to our web interface,
You can see we now have environment station
on each of our agent nodes.
Okay. Exercise four is going to guide us
through, not guide us. It wants us to
do something and hopefully we're gonna do the
guiding. Going well so far. By exercise four
is we want to have dynamic labels. And
this is one of my favorite features in
Teleport is that you can actually have Teleport
on a periodic interval
or
periodically or on an interval,
run a command and then use that output
to work out what the labels should be
on some of your machines.
So what we're going to try and do
with this
is,
yeah,
see you Waleed, catch you next time. And
what we're going to do with this is
see if we can add an app NGINX
when NGINX is running. So we're going to
actually install NGINX onto one of our agents.
Another one is to see, well, we actually
get a counter with the number of users
that are on the machine presently as a
label? So we may want to be able
to try and target machines that have more
than one active user.
All right. So dynamic labels are also just
covered here.
Think they are labels.
It's just the one page.
Here we go.
Where we can say, okay,
run these commands.
Let's copy and paste that as an example.
Jump over to here. I'm going to turn
off my broadcast.
In fact, no, we'll add
the user counter first. In fact, we'll add
plus that. We're going to add all the
labels.
That's what we're doing.
There's something to here. We're going to go
to SSH. You can see we've already got
a host name one here anyway.
So we'll say name,
nginx.
The command is,
well, we don't know what that is yet.
We've got a period.
So for NGINX, we actually specify in the
workshop that we want this updated every fifteen
minutes.
We don't really expect NGINX to disappear,
so we don't have to run it as
frequently.
What we're going to do here
is check for
ES, AUX,
grep,
NGINX.
That's always gonna return.
See, I came up with these challenges and
didn't actually think about how I was gonna
complete them.
We can do
p grep nginx.
That should work, right?
Let's test it. P grep nginx,
not running.
And so for one,
p grep, p grep.
Oh, maybe it didn't find it because I'm
in the process. P grep Teleport.
There we go. Perfect.
So let's do it what we want.
And now we need one more.
This is our user
account.
Let's run this every,
what does the workshop say?
Thirty seconds.
We want to execute.
Okay. User account. So we could do who,
wc dash l.
So who
wc
l.
Excuse me.
Let's save that from Teleport start.
Broke it. Oh, and the syntax is
Good point, but I'll even be able to
do a tape.
Let's try.
That's one.
So that's definitely gonna fix the PGRAPH.
I'm not sure if the Who is gonna
work.
Yeah. Okay.
Okay. How can we do that without piping?
Does wc take a command parameter?
No. Okay. So we could always try and
cheat. Thought, see, I don't really know how
Teleport does
this. So what we could do
is WC does work with standard input.
And I'm curious,
like if we do,
So it takes a fail doesn't it? Okay.
User can.
And that's the way I know how to
do it.
Oh, there we go.
And
we've got users equals two.
Short version.
That doesn't add anything.
Let's just go with it.
Who does queue.
Oh, and I got this syntax wrong again.
Little better.
Okay. So we're still getting something about an
up label field to update, but let's just
ignore that for now and see what we've
got.
Hey, look at that. We do have a
user account, which is cool.
However, we can exit status one on NGINX.
Yeah, that's failing because
NGINX isn't running.
Okay,
so we're going to install NGINX on one
of these machines.
So now I do need to disable
broadcast.
And this is, I think this is the
red hot one.
Cool.
So I'm going to rebroadcast
and
start.
Oh, it didn't run it here. We don't
really need to do it that often anyway,
so
and
there we go.
It's a bit hacky,
but we do have the user account on
both of these
machines as labels.
We see it NGINX is running here and
we have a PET, we have an error
here.
So I could always just tell pcrep not
to care
about
the exit code.
Or maybe you can't.
Not important.
Oh, my broadcast is working again.
Okay. What about pgrep dash cam internet?
Here we go. It's either one or two
there. That's a bit nicer. So let's do
that.
And then we'll move on to the next
exercise because this is not terribly important. I'm
just
having fun.
There we go. So we got NGINX with
an output of zero. We still get an
exit code.
I'm sure I can silence that somehow. And
we got our user account over here and
we've got two NGINX processes here.
So the whole point of the exercise
is to show how you can run arbitrary
commands on an interval, pull them onto your
labels. And then as we move through the
other exercises, we'll see how we can use
that as part of our QWERTY and command
execution criteria.
All right, exercise five is we're going to
sprinkle some eBPF dust.
So I'm kind of glad we kicked out
that debugging machine running the four nineteen kernel.
I'm not sure how that would have fared
here,
but we can enable enhanced recording on our
notes
and check out some of the cool things
that that does. So
again, we want to jump over. I'm just
going to do this on agents. We're not
too fussed about the server.
We're gonna make a change to our Teleport
configuration.
We're gonna rely on the docs to do
that, of course. So we search for enhanced
session recording,
this changes the way that Teleport does session
recording. And we'll take a look at what
that actually is, but let's get the enhancements
on first.
And that means we can actually see all
of the commands executed on logged and auditable
sessions that Teleport provides.
In order to turn this on, if we
go to here
and we add enhanced recording enabled true to
our SSH service.
SSH,
Let me see.
Enhanced
recording.
Yes.
Oh, not enabled.
Enabled,
yes.
And then if we restart Teleport,
oh.
No BPF.
Darn it.
514,
5 13.
That should be all right.
58.
Now this I have tested before.
So that's very disappointing.
We do have secret V2.
That should have worked.
Kevin saying enabling BPF on Red Hat could
be a bit annoying.
Yeah, I'm not entirely sure. I mean, one
of these machines is Arch.
So I actually think that's maybe something
that Linode are doing with our kernels on
the VM images
rather than operating system specific,
But definitely as in field to load BPF
object.
Let's see what this I mean, I'm not
really
I still have to spend a few minutes
looking to see what the problem is.
This is just
Okay, I'm trying to do just like this
is a little old kernel thing. And I
don't know
if I wanna try and fix this.
So that's unfortunate.
They have not had this working on Delta
Evolution.
Let's just try adding the secret path just
in case. But the default value is
correct.
Darn it.
Okay.
We're gonna skip this one. I'll do another
tutorial on this with machines that I know
have BPF enabled in the kernel.
However, what this does is actually uses BPF
probes
to record the sessions, which means you actually
see the system calls, the commands that are
being executed, parameters have been passed to them,
the observability and visibility into what's happening on
your server is much greater than what you
get by default.
So,
okay. So exercise six is managing users. We
want to create a new user called Leet
with
the admin role, which has access to all
nodes.
We've kind of seen this already because I
had to create my root user. So we
can do a TCL tool,
TCCL
users add.
This takes a whole bunch of parameters.
Now,
I'm only going to cover roles and logins
a little bit in this workshop. We have
an entire workshop dedicated to a deep dive
on roles.
Essentially, there are some preset roles that come
with Web Teleport.
Admin gives you access to everything.
There's also editor,
auditor
and access.
Access would just give you the ability to
kind of SSH across the nodes. Auditor gives
you the ability to
audit stuff for the UI
and then just edit an admin, which exposes
more ability to create users, manage users, etcetera.
So for now, we're just going to do
roles admin,
logins is
which logins we want to allow access to
on the machines.
So I'm not, again, I'm using Linode because
it's fast and cheap, but I'm not sure
how their emojis are configured.
I'm very quickly going to take a look
at the shadow file.
I think we only get on the Red
Hat image. I don't see
another one on Arch. We don't really get
any other users either. Okay. So we're only
actually getting I was expecting to see like
a boon to, or maybe we see
CentOS or to see Red Hat or some
non privileged user. Again, this is just image
configuration. So we'll just get root access right
now.
There and we can provide the name, which
we said we want to delete and like
so. We have now created a new user.
Now we can delete the user. So we
want to just show that command. So we'll
just do users
and you can just get all the subcommand
help by running dash help
and we can delete like so.
Next, create a new access user called PON.
This time we're going to modify the TTL
of forty eight hours.
And I'll talk about that in a minute
as I kind of explain what the invitations
actually do.
And then I said standard users with all
nodes, obviously me just looking to use Ubuntu
or that non root username,
which we don't have on these images.
So we're going to do pawn
TTL and I'll talk about that in a
moment.
And we want roles,
access,
logins, and I'm just going to do root
for today's workshop.
Okay, so what does the TTL mean? Well,
when you create an invite and you distribute
this link to someone, it's only gonna be
valid for a short period of time. By
default, I think it was one or two
hours. In fact, if we scroll up to
delete user,
whatever.
But that may not be long enough, you
don't know when the person's going to get
to it. The highest you can set it
to is forty eight hours, which is that
as an example, but it just means that
user has forty hours to accept this invitation,
create their account and have access to the
system.
Because this one is
access roles, the UI will be a little
bit different for them. So I'm actually going
to sign up as this user.
And we'll accept this again.
Let me reuse my password because I'm a
terrible human being.
Very weird thing to call myself actually.
And we're going to add our second to
FAQ this time.
Let's do edit first and rename the first
one.
Okay, so this is Rawkode
So I did that all screen, but when
I click this again, you'll see that I
just renamed
this Rawkode 2FE so that when I scan,
we're going to get Pawn 2FE. Well, it
won't be called that,
there we go. We get the other one
here.
So we can drop that in. We now
have a pawn user,
which has limited
access.
Oh, I don't expect the auto tool. What
did I do?
Alright, back to the moment.
So now we created that user.
Where are we? Oh, we're in our end.
Crap, okay.
So we want to use the SSH via
the user. Basically, just want to run who
am I who and last on
one or each of the nodes. So we'll
refresh this,
bring up those Teleport starts again.
Oh, that's the server.
There
we go.
Okay, so we got our knowns back. So
let's join the control plan.
We run am I?
And we see them, and I asked that
we run each of these commands on a
different machine. So we got Who am I
there.
We've got who here, we can see it's
connected.
And then on the last one, we'll run
last, which will show us the auto log
for the machine. And we can see who
is here, etcetera.
So the web UI provides a really great
way to be able to understand
the machines that we have on our infrastructure,
connect to them, run commands,
very, very cool.
I'm a huge fan of this user interface.
All right, so now we want to join
an active session. So
we can't create a standard user because of
the emojis, which is unfortunate. So we're just
going to use root and I want to
execute cat shadow.
Okay. So I'm going to join our Arch
machine,
run cat,
etcetera,
shadow.
And this is our shadow password file on
Linux.
Then it says
open password file on VIM. Okay. As it
says,
and we have this,
and then it wants us to use the
PON user to have sessions side by side.
So let's do that.
There is this tab.
I'll pop up in this one.
Really, I shouldn't be back in.
Let's just log in.
Accept.
So that should just work. Although I need
to change the off to FA to be
my Pawn user.
Pawn.
We're
going to go to activity and active sessions.
This is one of my, this is one
of Teleport's superpowers.
I absolutely love this feature and that we
can see active sessions and not only that,
but we can join
and you'll see that I'm dropped in
to the session.
And in fact, if I move the cursor
on one side, it moves
and the other.
So I'm not super cool.
So if I type,
immediately replicated to our other user, really great
for our pure programming scenarios or debugging and
production outages where you just need an extra
set of eyes to make sure that you're
not doing anything too catastrophic.
Very, very cool feature.
And then quite fine without saving, we shouldn't
have been able to save, but I'm sure
it's actually would have been able to save,
but I didn't. So we're all good.
Okay. So we're going to close this. I
don't think we need our join session anymore.
Exercise nine is to show off session replay.
So let's actually watch the recording of the
previous exercise.
So if we jump over to here and
go to activity and session recordings, you'll see
that each of the sessions that I have
opened
on one of our Teleport agents
is available here for us to play.
So that should be the first one.
There's a who am I, but I got
that wrong.
Which one's this? Is this the who? Yep.
And the last.
Where's
why is it still open?
Exit.
Okay, there we go.
So now we can actually see
we have the recording for that previous session,
which I hadn't closed, but we can see
the users that were involved in the session,
how long it was opened, when it was
created
and the session ID so we can actually
replay it. Let me take a look at
the command line very shortly where we'll see
that in action.
But we can come into here and we
can replay this.
Let's
see what our next task is.
So it wants us to copy the hash
password of the Aventura user, which I cannot
do because of the images. However,
I just want to demonstrate
how special the replay is. Like it kind
of, they make it look like a video
and that you can kind of drag and
drop, but it's not by any means a
video.
And in fact, you can copy and paste.
Oh, this is a Firefox thing.
Am I going to have to join in
Chrome?
Oh, damn you.
I don't know why Firefox is not letting
me copy and paste.
So I'm gonna bring over a Chrome window.
Oh, wait. There
we go.
Log in.
So if we pause this,
you can see we can copy and paste.
I thought it might Firefox, I've never seen
that before,
but these are not videos. So, you know,
if there was a piece of information that
you had to get, you can copy,
you you can paste that anywhere.
You can pick and choose part
of the replay that's important to you and
get what you need out of it.
Thank you Chrome.
Firefox.
I really just need to give up on
you, I think.
Well, replays very, very cool. I
like that a lot.
Okay. We are on good twenty five minutes,
exercise 10.
Find the join event and teleport auto log.
From here, we can see auto log
and we can just filter this down. So
if you're looking for a specific event or
you want to know, or you're looking to
see activity of a specific user even,
I can search for Rawkode,
but we are looking for the join event,
so I can search for join. And we
can see that the user Pawn joined this
session and we can click on details to
get more of it.
And if we were able to enable the
eBPF enhanced recording for the sessions,
we'd have been able to do some cool
stuff. In fact, one of the next exercises
would have been doing that.
You can actually put out a list of
all of the commands that were executed, the
parameters and stuff like that. So
I'm
just going to throw in an extra tutorial
on this course, and we're going to take
a look at the BPS stuff because that
is super cool.
But we've got the audit log.
There are different ways that you can interact
with that. I'm pretty sure we have a
small tutorial towards the end of the course
where we look at getting that information into
a time series database that's storing it in
Influx,
Prometheus, and it's like that. So you can
have very good visibility into what's happening in
your infrastructure.
Okay,
next.
So
for the final part
of this workshop, we want to, you know,
we've focused heavily so far on the user
interface and the user interface is obviously great.
But a lot of you, a lot of
people that are going to be coming to
watch this course
are going to be CLI junkies, right? You
work in your terminal all day and
interacting with your infrastructure should be no exception,
especially, or even when we bring Teleport into
the equation. So we want to take a
look at, well, can we use the Teleport
CLI tooling to do most of the same
stuff that we have already covered thus far?
So exercise 11 is just, hey,
let's get TSH working and be able to
interact with this cluster.
The one thing I just need is our
public IP address and the port.
Actually, I don't need the protocol.
We just need this.
And if we jump over to my, this
is my host machine. I'll just jump into
a temporary directory,
but we have access to the TSH command
and you can see that we have the
ability to, you know, SSH and execute commands.
We can list applications. We're going to be
looking at application proxy and
other workshop leaders. We'll come back for that,
as well as database access, which I think
we're going be doing our first one next
week.
We can join sessions. We can replay the
sessions locally too. We can copy files, list
machines,
work with multiple clusters, etcetera, etcetera. So there's
lots of stuff here.
The request stuff, I'm really excited to be
doing a tutorial on the soon, but we'll
look at how you can elevate your privilege.
So having your Teleport configured in a way
that people only have the bare minimum that
they need to do their job. And then
anything that they need above and beyond that,
maybe
they need access to a database server. Maybe
they need root on a database server or
root on a server that they typically only
have the Bindu access to. Well, we can
allow them to submit requests for elevated privilege
and be able to audit that in Proxy
as well.
And of course the Kubernetes and, you know,
there'll be a tutorial on hardware tokens as
well. There's just so much to love about
Teleport.
Okay. So let's do Teleport login and we
have to provide a proxy path, which is
gonna be our IP address and port.
I'm gonna need to unsecure again,
the next time I'm configuring
a DNS name.
So this is one to our password for
our Teleport user
that we can grab.
Teleport
workshop.
Copy password.
My token.
I get the Rawkode one.
Enter password
for Rawkode.
Yeah.
Token.
No
idea what happened there. As you can actually
see, I have a fair number of Teleport
clusters because I use Teleport every single week
for cluster.
So I'm always, I've always got access to
stuff.
We can actually clean that up.
Config.
Where does it live again?
Why is my brain not working?
There we go. There they are out there.
Okay.
Let's clean
FHAT star cluster.
I probably remove all of those.
TSH.
Yeah, that works.
So if I do TSH
clusters,
much better. So we've tidied that up.
Each of your Teleport cluster is left to
this one file. You can
current one that you're working with is literally
just stored the name instead of current profile.
That's it.
And that just matches the file name of
the YAML for the cluster that we're working
with.
Okay. So we got TSH
configured, which was our mission there. Let's jump
back.
So create a session on one of our
nodes through the UI and then we're going
to join it using TSH.
So let's pop open.
Let's just pick one of these ones.
So now we have a session.
Unless this has changed,
there's one caveat to this exercise.
And I don't think it has, I don't
think it has changed is that you can't
list
the sessions
from the CLI, unfortunately.
So in order for us to join
using the join command here,
we have to grab the ID from either
the URL of the session, or if you
don't have that from active sessions here, where
you can get the session ID.
That's the caveat.
I'm sure that will improve
soon.
From here, we can run a TSH join
and we just want to provide the session
ID.
Yeah, we need a
108 session ID. So I have to provide
a user separately.
So that was going to be
rich.
And from here, I can run the PSE
UX like the workshop wants me to, and
I would jump over to the web here.
We've got the same here.
So,
you don't
lose any functionality by wanting or opting for
using the CLI.
And in fact, I actually find the CLI
experience a little bit nicer,
except for that really annoying caveat about finding
the session ID.
So let's drop out of that.
Session was closed.
Okay. We're almost there and we may just
sneak in on time because I'm not sure
we can do all the following exercises because
of that
annoying BPF thing. However,
we want to create a file on all
staging nodes. So now we're going to be
taking a look at how we use those
label selectors to query our infrastructure.
So if we run TSH
LS,
what we get are a list of all
of the agents, machines, VMs, bare metal, whatever
that are joined as part of the cluster.
And one of the cool things you can
do is pass in label selectors.
Oh, he says,
hopefully.
Oh, it's environment.
Hey, that actually worked.
Environment
staging.
I'm making it more difficult for myself.
So we can use those label selectors to
take a look.
I'd not actually tried this, but I'm now
feeling
a little bit brave. I'm not sure
how fancy those can get. Let's see if
we can just wrap in quotes first, which
we can.
Can we do
I'm making this up now.
Star.
No, I was curious if we could do
like, oh, it doesn't look like this. And
I'm sure there are
potentially patterns here. Oh no, it just wants
key value. That
would've been awesome.
So we can use the label selectors to
do a variable station and we can definitely
open a feature request for maybe like Google's
common expression language as a way to filter
those down even better.
So very cool.
All right, workshop.
So now we actually, yeah. So all we've
done is query
node list based on that, but we actually
want to execute commands. And if we take
a look at the SSH subcommand,
you'll see that we can
use TSHSSH.
We could tell the nodes that we want
to communicate to.
Let's see.
And we can run a command. Okay.
Well, I thought this is gonna work, but
I don't think it is.
User.
Secure.
Oh, that's the wrong user.
Login.
Okay.
Sorry about that. So
what did we do there? Well, we ran
TSS SSH. Then secured because of my TLS
configuration.
We've done -l root, not -l equals root,
should be -login equals root or -l space
root. Anyway, And for the host, we use
the label selector, which will allow us to
run arbitrary commands across one or more machines.
You can see here that we run LS
on the home directory and we can see
the binaries, the tarballs that we downloaded earlier.
If we run a Uname A, we'll also
see the environments or the configurations for each
of these machines, allowing us to see that
we have an harsh machine.
We have a Linux machine, which is the
Red Hat one.
And
I don't know why I only got two
of this. There should be three, right?
L s.
Yeah.
No idea.
And we can run whatever command we want
there. So the workshop wants us to actually
echo hi hello to a fail on each
of these nodes.
So we can say echo
hi
temp
Teleport.
Hello.
My terminal
is acting up.
I need to call it that's because of
the redirect.
Echo high, I'm just going to attempt
H.
Now that fits.
So then we actually get this command on
each node and then we can actually see,
well, let me take a look at tempH.
We will see high and high.
Oh yeah, and the reason we're only getting
two on the selector is we never updated
intentionally
at the start,
the label on the control plane. So if
I pop back here,
we still have ENV example here. So there
we go.
Makes sense when you understand.
Now what I wanted to be able to
do
is
Oh no, we can't do this one. It's
just
Okay, cool.
The EBPF exercise would have been cool, but
I actually didn't put that in anyway, we
got lucky.
So we want the IP address and the
UUID of every node in the Teleport cluster.
So when we run TSHLS,
we get some information back. What I really
like with us is this following the convention
of, you know, other tooling that we have
around right now, specifically kubectl,
where we can actually specify
an output parameter.
Format, sorry.
Yeah, I'm using the kubectl
syntax,
where we can say, Hey, here's the information
that we need. So we have this as
JSON. And if we're just looking to get
the IP and the UID, then we can
take a look at, in fact, if we
just pipe it through JQ,
then we could see that what we're after
is
so we've got a list, we've got a
node, where's the IP?
Public ADDR, should spec.
Public ADDR.
So we can see, all right, we want
spec,
public
ADDR.
What is spec?
Now I can't remember JQ, come on.
Yeah, that should be right, right? Cannot index
array with strings back.
I forget it has to do all array
thingy.
Oh, dreads.
You know, I don't always know the answers
to all items that are ready.
Oh, am I just missing the dot?
There we go.
So
simple when you look at our route. So
because of the configuration we have of this
Teleport cluster right now is that these two
are actually being proxied through the control plane
node. And we're using that in a kind
of bastion style setup, but the only node
we have an IP address is for this
one. And then if we wanted to get
the UID,
that would just be
metadata.
Name.
And we can get all the UIDs.
But of course, I don't really have any
rhyme or reason for this right now. I
just really like the fact that we have
the ability with the TSH command
to format and get the human readable output
and something that is machine readable and be
able to enter at that using tooling that
we're already comfortable with such as JQ.
All
right.
Well,
that is our first workshop.
I will tidy that up for anyone who's
watching this a little bit in the future.
That's maybe slightly different,
but I will make sure that the description
contains all our comments
for everything that you need to know. There's
lots more content coming on the Complete Guide
to Teleport. I hope this piques your interest.
I hope you like what you see. It's
a very cool tool
and we'll be back next week with more
workshops and more fun.
So have a wonderful day. I'll see you
all again soon.